we're declaring war against cancer and
we will win this war by 2015 this is
what the US Congress and the National
Cancer Institute declared just just a
few years ago in 2003 now I don't know
about you but I'm from what I do I don't
buy that I don't think we quite won this
war yet and I don't think anyone here
will question that now I will argue that
a primary reason why we're not winning
this war against cancer is because we're
fighting bind Lee so I'm going to start
by just sharing your little story but a
good friend of mine his name is a hood
and a few years ago I was diagnosed with
brain cancer and not just any type of
brain cancer he was diagnosed with one
of the most deadly forms of brain cancer
in fact it was so deadly that the
doctors told him that they only have 12
months and during those 12 months they
have to find the treatment they have to
find a cure and if they cannot find a
cure he will die now the good news they
said is that there are tons of different
treatments to choose from but the bad
news is that in order for them to tell
if a treatment is even working or not
well that takes them about three months
or so so they cannot try that many
things well held is now going into his
first treatment and during that first
written just a few days into that
treatment I'm living with him and he
tells me Adam you know I think this is
working I think we really lucked out
here right something's happening and
that's agree how do you know that they
hood and he says well I feel so terrible
inside something's gotta be working up
there it just has to well unfortunately
you know three months later we got the
news it didn't work and so it goes into
a second treatment and again the same
story it feels it feels so bad
something's gotta be working there and
then three months later again we get bad
news I would discuss going into history
treatment and then his fourth treatment
and then as predicted who dies now when
someone really close to is going through
such a huge struggle you know you get
three swamped with emotions a lot of
things are going through your head for
me it was mostly outrage
I was just out
that that how come this is the best that
we can offer and I started looking more
and more into this as it turns out this
is not just the best the doctors could
offer a hood it's not just the best
doctors could offer patients with brain
cancer generally we're actually not
doing that well all across the board
with cancer I picked up one of those
statistics and and I'm sure some of you
have seen those statistics before this
is gonna show you here how many patients
actually died of cancer in this case
females in the United States ever since
in 1930s you'll notice that there aren't
that many things that have changed it's
still a huge issue you'll see a few
changes there you'll see lung cancer for
example on the rise Thank You cigarettes
and you'll also see that for example
stomach cancer once used to be one of
the biggest killers of all cancers has
essentially eliminated now why is that
anyone knows by the way why is it that
that humanity is no longer struck by
stomach cancer
what was the cheer is huge medical
technology breakthrough that came to our
world that saved humanity from from
stomach cancer was it maybe a new drug
or a better diagnostic you guys all
right yeah it's the invention of the
refrigerator and the fact that we're no
longer eating spoiled meats so the best
thing that happened to us so far in
medical arena of cancer research is the
fact that refrigerator was invented and
so so yes I know so this we're not doing
so well here and I don't want to I don't
want to miniaturize the progress and the
rent and everything that's been done in
cancer research look there's like 50
plus years of good Cancer Research that
discovered major major things that
taught us about cancer but all that said
we have a lot of heavy lifting to still
do ahead of us again I will argue that
the primary reason why this is the case
why we've not done that remarkably well
is really worth fighting blindly here
and this is where medical imaging comes
in this is where my own work comes in
and so to give you a sense of the best
medical imaging that's that's offered
today to brain cancer patients or
actually generally to all cancer
patients take a look at this bat scan
right here
let's see tarragon so this is a PET CT
scan and what you'll see in this PET CT
scan is the CT scan will show you where
the bones are
and the PET scan will show you where
tumors are now what you're gonna see
here is essentially a sugar molecule
that was added the small little tag that
is signaling to us outside of the body
hey I'm here and those sugar molecules
are injected into these patients by the
billions and they're going all over the
body looking for cells that are hungry
for sugar you'll see that the heart for
example lights out there that's because
the heart needs a lot of sugar you'll
also see that the bladder lights up
there that's because the bladder is -
think that's clearing the sugar away
from our body and then you'll see if the
other hotspots are and these are in fact
the tumors though this is really a
wonderful technology for the first time
it allowed us to look into someone's
body without picking up each other one
of the cells and putting it under a
microscope but in a non-invasive way
allowing us to look into someone's body
and ask hey has the cancer metastasized
is is where is it and PET scans here
showing it very clearly where are these
hotspots water where it's a tumor so
this is as as known as miraculous as
this might seem unfortunately well it's
it's not that great you see those small
little hotspots there anyone guess how
many cancer cells are in any one of
these tumors so it's about 100 million
cancer cells and let make sure that this
number sunk in in each every one of
these smaller blips that you're seeing
on the image there needs to be at least
100 million cancer cells in order to be
detected now if that seemed to you like
a very large number it is a very large
number this is in fact incredibly large
number because what we really need in
order to pick up something early enough
to do something about its do something
meaningful about it well we need to pick
up tumors there are thousand cells in
size and ideally just a handful of cells
in size so we're clearly pretty far away
from this so we're gonna play a little a
little experiment here I'm gonna ask
each of you to now play and imagine that
you are brain surgeons and and you guys
are you're now at at an operating room
and there's a patient in front of you
and your task is to make sure that the
tumor is out so you're looking down at
the patient and as you're looking down
at the patient the skin and the skull
have already been removed so you're
looking at the brain
and then only know about these patients
that there's a tumor about the size of a
golf ball or so in the right frontal
lobe of this person's brain and that's
more or less it and so so you're looking
down and unfortunately everything looks
the same because brain cancer tissue and
healthy brain tissue really just look
the same and so you're going in with
your thumb and you start to press a
little bit on the brain because you see
because tumors tend to be a little
harder a lot stiffer and so you go in
like there you go a little bit in
existence oh yeah it seems like the
tumors right there then you take out
your and then you take out your knife
and start cutting the tumor piece by
piece by piece and as you're taking the
tumor out then you're getting to a stage
where do you think all right I'm done I
I took out everything and at this stage
if that's so far everything sounded like
pretty crazy
well you're not about to face the most
challenging decision of your life here
because now you need to decide should I
stop here and let this patient go
risking that there might be some
leftover cancer cells behind the ledger
I just couldn't see or should I take
away some extra margins typically about
an inch or so around the tumor just to
be sure that I removed everything this
is not a simple decision to make and an
unfortunate this is the decision that
that brain cancer surgeons have to take
every single day as they're saying their
patients and so I remember talking to if
you're friends of mine in the lab you
say boy there's got to be a better way
but but not just you know like you tale
friendly there's got to be a better way
no no there's just there's just got to
be a better way here all right this is
just incredible and so we looked back
you remember those PET scans are told
him but the sugar and so on we said hey
how about if instead of using those
sugar molecules let's let's maybe take a
tiny tiny little particles made of gold
and and let's program them in with some
interesting chemistry around and let's
program them to look for cancer cells
and then we'll inject these gold
particles into these patients by the
billions again and we'll have them go
all over the body and just like secret
agents if you will go and walk by every
single cell in our body and knock on the
door of that cell and ask a your cancer
cell or your healthy cell if your
healthy cell we're moving on if you're a
cancer cell we're sticking in and
shining out and telling us outside by
the hey look at me I'm here and they'll
do it through some interesting cameras
that we developed in the lab and once we
see that the
we can guide brain cancer surgeons
towards taking only the tumor and living
two healthy brain alone and so we've
tested that and boy this works well so
I'm gonna show you an example now what
you're looking at here is an image of a
mouse's brain and we've implanted into
this mouse's brain a small little tumor
and so this tumor is now growing in this
mouse's brain and then we've taken a
doctor and we asked the doctor to please
operate on the mouse as if that was a
patient and take out piece-by-piece out
of the tumor and and while he's doing
that we're gonna take images to see
where the gold particles are and so
we're gonna first start by injecting
these gold particles at his mouse and
we're gonna see right here at the very
left there that image at the bottom is
the image to chose for the gold
particles and you see that nice thing is
that these gold particles actually made
it all the way to the tumor and then
they shine out and tell us hey we're
here here's the tumor so now we consider
tumor but we're not trying this to the
doctor yet we're asking the doctor now
please start cutting away the tumor and
you'll see here they doctor just took
the first quadrant of the tumor and you
see that first quadrant is now missing
the doctor then took the second quadrant
the third and now it appears would be
everything and so at this stage the
doctor came back to us and say alright
I'm done what do you want me to do sure
keep things as they are or do you want
me to take some extra margins around and
then we said well hang on we told the
doctor you've missed those two spots so
you rather than taking huge margins
around only take out those tiny little
areas take them out and then let's take
a look and so the doctor took them away
and lo and behold the cancer is not
completely gone now the important thing
is that it's not just that the cancer is
completely gone from this person's brain
or from this mouse's brain the most
important thing is that we did not have
to take huge amounts of of healthy brain
in the process and so now we can
actually imagine the world where doctors
and surgeons as they take away the tumor
they actually know what to take out and
they don't know long have to guess with
that them now here's why that's
extremely important to take those tiny
little leftover tumors those leftover
tumors even if it's just a handful of
cells they will grow to recur the tumor
for the tumor to come back in fact the
reason why 80 to 90 percent of those
brain
cancer surgeries ultimately fail is
because of those small little extra
margins that were left positive those
small little leftover tumors at the left
there so this is clearly very nice but
what I want to really share with you is
where I think we're heading from here
and so in my lab at Stanford my students
and I are trying this askance of order
to what's what should we be working on
now and I think we're in medical imaging
is heading to is the ability to look
into the human body and actually see
each and every one of these cells
separately the ability like this would
allow us to to actually pick up tumors
way way early in the process way before
it's a hundred million cells inside so
we can actually do something about it an
ability to to see each other one of the
cells might also allow us to ask
insightful questions so in the lab we're
now getting to a point where we can
actually start asking these these cancer
cells real questions like for example
are you responding to the treatment
we're giving you or not so if you're not
responding Weedon will know to stop the
treatment right away days into the
treatment not three months and also for
patients like a hood that are going
through these nasty nasty chemotherapy
and drugs for them not to suffer through
those horrendous side effects of the
drugs with drugs are in fact not even
helping them so to be frank here were
pretty far away from from winning the
war against cancer just to be realistic
but at least I'm hopeful that we should
be able to fight this war with better
medical imaging techniques in a way that
is not blind thank you